you know it's funny sometimes American
journalists talk about how bad the
country is the people are lining up for
food
that's a good thing in other countries
people don't line up food the rich get
the food and the poor starve to death
the distribution of wealth in this
country is one of the most unfair and
distorted in the entire world I think
you change your food tax tax more I
think you change it through public
ownership of significant parts of the
economy everybody was totally convinced
that Castro was the worst guy in the
world they thought that he educated the
kids gave them health care totally
transform a society throughout his
career Vermont senator Bernie Sanders
has explained away the inevitable
downsides of massively increasing the
power of the state over the individual
it's a dictatorship it's a poor economy
we want changes but have some good
things went on in Cuba yes
Sanders once identified as a radical
socialist who admired the achievements
of Cuba under Fidel of Nicaragua under
the Sandinistas and of the Soviet Union
right up to the fall of the Berlin Wall
their public transportation was the
cleanest most effective mass transit
system that I've ever seen in my life
the station's themselves were absolutely
beautiful including many works of art
chandeliers that were beautiful running
for office in Vermont in the 70s
Sanders sought a top tax rate of 100
percent saying nobody should earn more
than a million dollars Sanders wanted to
stop businesses from moving out of their
original communities saying the ultimate
solution to protect workers was national
legislation that would bring about the
public ownership of the major means of
production he favored the public
ownership of utilities banks and major
industries without compensation to
investors or stockholders face it you
don't find too many socialists in
elective office in this country and one
is elected mayor of a sizable city well
that's news shortly after he was elected
mayor of Burlington Vermont in 1981
Sanders told a roomful of charity
workers I don't believe in charities
because only the government should
provide social services to the needy
though I believe that the profit motive
is fundamental to human nature the
answer is no I think the spirit of
cooperation you and I can work together
better rather than having to compete
against each other in Detroit to destroy
each other healthcare is a right
today Sanders calls himself a Democratic
Socialist and has himself become a
millionaire
I wrote a best-selling book
he favors single-payer health care free
public college for all and a $15 minimum
wage what I'm talking about Venezuela
we're not talking about Cuba so the next
time that you hear me attacked as a
socialist remember this I don't believe
government should take over you know the
grocery store down the street our own
means of production but one thing has
remained constant as Sanders has shifted
his model for US policy from Nicaragua
Cuba and the USSR to Denmark Finland and
Sweden in all of these countries he's
misled his followers about what's really
happening as a socialist the word
socialism does not frighten me and I
think it's probably fair to say that the
Nicaraguan government is primarily a
socialist government the government
there has the strange and unusual idea
that they should attempt to do something
for the people of Nicaragua rather than
for the United States corporations they
are now teaching poetry not only to
peasants and to workers but in the in
the military in the police department
when Sanders was the mayor of Burlington
Vermont he vowed that his city would
defy the Reagan administration's embargo
against Nicaragua and the Sandinistas
who had overthrown an american-backed
dictator and instituted a revolutionary
socialist government in 1985 Sanders
traveled to Nicaragua to attend a
celebration in honor of the revolution
sixth anniversary
I mean if it's unbelievable to say that
a mayor of the city of 38,000 is now the
highest-ranking American to visit them
during the celebration of that
revolution might was treated you know in
a special way
surrounded by reporters at the airport
upon his return Sanders was enthusiastic
about what he had seen in Nicaragua many
of the things that we saw were
impressive there's a tremendous sense of
energy Sanders praised the Sandinista
leadership and President Daniel Ortega
what a good is an impressive guy Ernesto
Cardenal is that there's a funny looking
guy's grey hair and he really does
remind you of the hippie they are not to
quote Ronald Reagan Looney tune
characters I just went all around and
stop people asking why are you with the
government or not I kind of laughed they
don't quite understand what you're
talking about of course there was the
government now obviously I will be
attacked by every editorial writer and
the Free Press were being a dumb dude
maybe I am I was impressed by their
intelligence and by their sincerity
these are not
has he praised the seizure of private
farms and businesses in terms of land
reform giving for the first time in
their lives real land performance and
people of Nicaragua the poor people
respect that rich people needless to say
who used to have the good life there are
not terribly happy what Sanders didn't
mention was that by 1985 international
watchdog groups had exposed the
Sandinistas significant human rights
violations a 1981 report by the
inter-american Commission on Human
Rights revealed mass executions and
persecution of indigenous peoples and
just two years before Sanders made his
trip Time magazine reported that
hundreds of citizens were disappearing
every month at the hands of the
Sandinistas many of us get depressed
about what's going on in Nicaragua today
the absolute blocks that are coming out
of the White House in fact we have a
right to be very exhilarating Sanders
accused the American government and
media of conspiring to cover up a
socialist success story the important
story is not Nicaragua when you read the
New York Times the real truth is not
being told and how that's off escaped
okay that's what the interesting story
if you get on the air and you say I'm
sympathetic to the sandanista government
I think it was right they made their
revolution they're trying to do the
right thing
nobody my point who Ortega is they are
not getting their message of what they
are trying to do out to the American
people I just came back from a 14-hour
trip so I the Sandinistas would remain
in power for five more years after
Sanders his visit and the Nicaraguan
Permanent Commission on Human Rights
would go on to document over 14,000
instances of rape torture and murder
during their reign they really were
talking about a transformation of
society giving power to the poor people
to the working people and that has
caused the conflict needless to say in
Nicaragua which was same thing I
[Music]
remember for some reason of being very
excited when when Fidel Castro made the
revolution in Cuba I was a kid learn
about freedom that just seemed bright
and appropriate the cool people were
rising up against ugly rich people while
Sanders was still mayor of Burlington
he traveled to Cuba in 1989 to seek a
meeting with Fidel Castro though he
ended up settling for the mayor of
Havana by this time Castro had seized
private farms and businesses imprisoned
artists created informant squad
to monitor and arrest dissenters and
forced gay citizens and other
undesirables into labor camps everybody
was totally convinced the Castro was the
worst guy in the world all the Cuban
people were gonna rise up in rebellion
against Fidel Castro
they'd forgot that he educated the kids
gave them health care totally
transformed the society you don't have
to say that Fidel Castro of Cuba are
perfect they are certainly not Castro
was open about his need to limit
individual rights in order to ensure
collective rights he understood that
curbing press freedoms was a
prerequisite for the success of a
socialist government saying he couldn't
tolerate dissidents in the mass media
because the people's cohesion is
fundamental if you ask us if their paper
could appear here against socialism like
we say - please no it cannot be in that
sense the freedom of the press a due
process in u.s. but Sanders disagreed
with Castro he thought the American
press was similarly compromised because
it was controlled by politicians and
big-money interests beginning to read
about the Cuban Revolution and find I
was more impressed about how it was
being reported in the United States
President began to understand but you
don't always hear all of the truth for
example just last night I was watching
Canadian television which we got down
here there was a program on Cuba we're
not allowed to see those programs here
in the United States just because Ronald
Reagan dislikes these people does not
need to say that the people in their own
nations feel the same way today the
Cuban government censors the internet
bans public displays of affection
between gay couples and jails people for
criticizing the government you could say
there's some positive things in Cuba
with some very negative things 50 years
after the Revolution people still can't
dissent with freedom the economy is
terrible but you know it's somehow
they've decided the Cuba is the only non
democratic country in the world
glory to the great Soviet people the
builders of communism and then a problem
with the word socialism is that very
often it's been equated with what
happens in the Soviet Union which is
authoritarianism in totalitarianism I
believe very strongly in the right of
the sent Sanders traveled to the Soviet
Union in 1988
three years before its collapse he had
gotten married to his second wife Jane
the day before leaving and the trip
doubled is what he called quote a very
strange honeymoon
sandurz formalized Burlington's
relationship with its russian sister
city Yaroslavl and praised the communist
government social and cultural
achievements we went to a theater in
Yaroslavl which was absolutely beautiful
and three separate stages including a
puppeteer
area and the cost the highest price of a
ticket that you can get was the
equivalent of a dollar fitting and route
home a journalist confronted him again
at the airport with reporting by The
Associated Press of dilapidated
unsanitary living conditions and food
shortages in Yaroslavl exhaust the study
of living conditions
I noticed later he said he was impressed
by Soviet officials transparency and
acknowledging their housing crisis which
he found comparable to America's we have
a major housing crisis which they
acknowledge but they acknowledge that
not only do they not have enough housing
but the construction and the quality of
the housing is also not adequate and
they were very free a dimension Airy but
you know one can't isolate a situation
saying what socialism has failed of that
compared to what you know that in the
United States of America today the
average married couple can no longer
afford a home Sanders also appreciated
the Soviets openness about other issues
and believed policymakers in the US had
much to learn from the communist system
they are absolutely open in
acknowledging that they are not a
democratic society the healthcare system
is free but they would be open to
acknowledge that it is probably 10 years
behind the United States in terms of
medical technology we were willing to be
critical of the United States we were
there to say yes we have problems you
have problems your strengths to your
system their strengths to our system our
goal was let's take the strengths of
both systems
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what I believe in has nothing to do with
communism after a failed run for
governor of Vermont in 1986 around the
fall of the Soviet Union Sanders said
his sights on higher office
you know we freed the slaves a long long
time ago but in many respects the
average working person today has very
little rights he rebranded himself a
Democratic Socialist and won a seat in
Congress in 1990 authoritarian communism
has been a vicious political system
which over its length of time has
resulted in the murder of many many
millions of people as an economic system
it has not succeeded and I am delighted
to see its demise that has nothing to do
with democratic socialism today Sanders
objects to comparisons between his
policies and those of the Sandinistas or
Castro's when I talk about democratic
socialism I'm not looking at Venezuela
I'm not looking at Cuba I'm looking at
countries like Denmark and Sweden what
hasn't changed is Sanders his
unwillingness to acknowledge the
political and economic realities of the
countries he points to his models
Scandinavia is a bastion of free market
capitalism in the libertarian Fraser
Institute's 2018 human freedom index
Norway Denmark and Finland ranked higher
than the United States and in 2015 the
danish prime minister directly
contradicted sanders his claims i know
that some people in in the u.s.
associate the nordic model was some sort
of socialism therefore i would like to
make one thing clear Denmark is far from
socialist plant economy it might
surprise some of you but Forbes last
year named Denmark the best country in
the world for business Denmark does
offer expansive social benefits
including single-payer health care free
education and months of paid family
leave what is the catch you could ask
and the most obvious one is of both the
high taxes the top income tax in Denmark
is almost 60% when you think about 90
percent you don't think that's obviously
too high no
Danish citizens also pay a 25% sales tax
and excise taxes on cars of up to 180
percent but tax revenue in Nordic
countries isn't enough to pay for their
social programs which are unsustainable
in their current form we have no choice
but to reform our society in order to
preserve the welfare state and the
public support wait
Sweden is raising its retirement age and
further privatizing parts of its health
care system in Finland the coalition
government recently resigned after it
failed to pass reforms it viewed as
crucial to averting financial ruin end
mark is increasing its retirement age to
73 and cutting spending and taxes the
answer cannot always be sent more money
I want to improve our competitiveness
reduce taxes for business remove red
tape Sanders also points to Norway as a
model a country where massive oil
production subsidizes the welfare
benefits of a population that's roughly
62 times smaller than in the US he never
acknowledges fundamental differences
between the Nordic countries in America
or the true costs of the policies he
champions Sanders wants to offer even
more generous benefits than those in
Scandinavia and thinks that the
wealthiest taxpayers can simply foot the
bill so you're saying we can pay for all
this without raising taxes on anybody
but the 1% may have to go down a little
bit lower than that but not much lower
Sanders has proposed a government
takeover of the health care sector or
about 18% of GDP at a cost of 32
trillion dollars over 10 years he wants
to increase Social Security benefits
offer free public college and grant the
state sweeping new powers to tackle
climate change to the green New Deal
policies that would add at least another
50 trillion to the budget when you're
dealing with the future of the planet I
don't know how you go too far these are
not radical extremist ideas I am NOT
coming before the American people and
say look I am this radical wild-eyed
socialist crazy ideas but listen to me
you know you have more and more growth
producing products that we do not
necessarily need I mean you know and the
end of the day you don't necessarily
need a choice of 23 under-armed spray do
hearts
or 18 different pairs of sneakers when
children are hungry in this country it's
all in keeping with his decades-long
pattern of ignoring the downsides of
centralizing authority and massively
increasing the size of the government
massive investments massive investments
massive investments massive investments
my vision is not just making modest
changes around the edge it is
transforming American society so when I
use the word socialist and I know some
people are uncomfortable about it I say
that it is imperative that we create a
political revolution and I hope you will
be part of that movement because if you
are we can in fact transform this
country so as American voters consider
whether to sign up for part 2 of Sanders
is political revolution it should
consider whether this time it really
will be different they really were
talking about a transformation of
society healthcare in Nicaragua is now
free it is terrible it is very primitive
compared from what we get but they now
have it free
[Music]